CHRISTOPHER FLANNERY:
Hi, I'm Chris Flannery,
a senior fellow of the
Claremont Institute,
contributing editor of the
Claremont Review of Books,
and host of The
American Story podcast.
Every generation of
Americans from the beginning
has had to answer for itself the
question, how should we live?
Our answers, generation after
generation, in war and peace,
in good times, in bad
times, in small things
and in great things, through the
whole range of human affairs,
are the essential threads of
the larger American story.
There is an infinite variety of
these smaller American stories
that shed light on the
moral and political reality
of American life.
And we keep creating them.
These fundamental experiences
known to all human beings,
but known to us in
an American way,
create the mystic chords of
memory that bind us together
as a people and are the
necessary beginnings
of any human wisdom
we might hope to find.
These mystic chords stretch
not only from battlefields
and patriot graves, but from
back roads, schoolyards and bar
stools, city halls, blues
joints, summer afternoons,
old neighborhoods, ballparks,
and deserted beaches,
from everywhere
you find Americans
being and becoming American.
A story may be tragic,
complicated, or hilarious.
But if it is a true
American story,
it will be impossible
to read or listen
to it attentively without
awakening the better
angels of our nature.
So here's one about the
beautiful friendship
of two remarkable Americans.
I call it "Fingertip Memories."
"Helen Keller was 14
years old when she first
met the world-famous
Mark Twain in 1894.
They became fast friends.
He helped arrange for her to go
to college at Radcliffe, where
she graduated in 1904--
the first deaf and blind
person in the world
to earn a Bachelor
of Arts degree.
She learned to read
English, French, German,
and Latin in Braille and went on
to become practically as world
famous as her dear friend,
writing prolifically
and lecturing across the
country and around the world.
Twain, with his
usual understatement,
called her one of the two
most remarkable people
in the 19th century.
His other candidate
was Napoleon."
I guess he forgot Lincoln.
"Keller lived into
the 1960s and shared
some of her fond
memories of Twain
in an autobiographical
book she published in 1929.
In particular, she
records recollections
from her last visit to her
friend in his Stormfield
home in Redding, Connecticut--
what she thought of as, in her
words, 'a land of enchantment.'
She preserves for us a vivid
image not only of Mark Twain--
Mr. Clemens, as she called him--
but of her own vivacious mind.
About Twain, she
writes, 'There are
writers who belong to the
history of their nation's
literature.
Mark Twain is one of them.
When we think of great
Americans, we think of him.
He incorporated the
age he lived in.
To me, he symbolizes
the pioneer qualities--
the large, free, unconventional,
humorous point of view of men
who sail new seas and blaze new
trails through the wilderness.'
As they gathered
around the hearth
one night after
dinner at Stormfield,
she records, 'Mr. Clemens stood
with his back to the fire,
talking to us.
There he stood, our Mark Twain,
our American, our humorist,
the embodiment of our country.
He seems to have absorbed
all America into himself.
The great Mississippi River
seems forever flowing,
flowing through his speech.'
When Twain took her to her
room to say good night,
he said, I would find
cigars and a thermos bottle
with scotch whisky or
bourbon, if I preferred it,
in the bathroom.
One evening, Twain
offered to read to her
from his short
story, Eve's Diary.
She was delighted.
And he asked, how
shall we arrange it?
She said, oh, you
will read aloud,
and my teacher will spell
your words into my hand.
He murmured, I had thought
you would read my lips.
So that's what she did.
Upon request, and as promised,
Twain put on his Oxford robe--
the gorgeous scarlet
robe he had worn
when Oxford University conferred
upon him the degree of Doctor
of Letters.
Here is Keller's
recollection of the evening.
'Mr. Clemens sat in
his great armchair,
dressed in his white serge
suit, the flaming scarlet robe
draping his shoulders, and
his white hair gleaming
and glistening in the light
of the lamp which shone down
on his head.
In one hand, he held Eve's
Diary in a glorious red cover.
In the other hand,
he held his pipe.
I sat down near him
in a little chair,
my elbow on the arm of his
chair so that my fingers
could rest lightly on his lips.
Everything went
smoothly for a time.
But Twain's gesticulations
soon began to confuse things,
and so a new setting
was arranged.
Mrs. Macy came and sat beside
me and spelled the words
into my right hand
while I looked at Mr.
Clemens with my left,
touching his face and hands
and the book, following his
gestures and every changing
expression.'
Keller reflected that, 'to
one hampered and circumscribed
as I am, it was a
wonderful experience
to have a friend
like Mr. Clemens.
I recall many talks with
him about human affairs.
He never made me feel that
my opinions were worthless.
He knew that we do not think
with our ears and eyes,
and that our
capacity for thought
is not measured by five senses.
He kept me always in
mind when we talked,
and he treated me like
a competent human being.
That is why I loved him.
There was about him the air of
one who had suffered greatly.
Whenever I touched his face,
his expression was sad,
even when he was
telling a funny story.
' He smiled not with his
mouth but with his mind--
a gesture of the soul
rather than of the face.
His voice was truly wonderful.
To my touch, it
was deep, resonant.
He had the power of modulating
it so as to suggest the most
delicate shades of meaning.
And he spoke so
deliberately that I
could get almost every word
with my fingers on his lips.
Ah, how sweet and
poignant the memory
of his soft, slow speech playing
over my listening fingers.
His words seemed to take
strange, lovely shapes
on my hands.
His own hands were wonderfully
mobile and changeable
under the influence of emotions.
It has been said that life
has treated me harshly.
And sometimes I have
complained in my heart,
because many pleasures
of human experience
have been withheld from me.
But when I recollect the
treasure of friendship
that has been bestowed upon
me, I withdraw all charges
against life.
If much has been
denied me, much--
very much-- has been given me.
So long as the memory of
certain beloved friends lives
in my heart, I shall
say that life is good.'
When Helen Keller left the
enchanted land of Stormfield
on that visit, she wondered if
she would ever see her friend
again, and she didn't.
It was 1909, and Clemens
would live just one year more.
But she writes for
us, 'In my fingertips
was graven the image
of his dear face,
with his halo of
shining white hair.
And in my memory, his drawling,
marvelous voice will always
vibrate.'"
So that's Fingertip Memories.
And here's another
one about an American
whose name the
whole world knows--
John Wayne.
"22-year-old Marion Morrison,
known to his friends as Duke,
was carrying a table on his head
across the soundstage of a John
Ford movie.
He was working as a
prop man in a Fox studio
in LA early in 1930.
Director Raoul Walsh was looking
for a leading man for an epic
Western he was developing
about a great wagon
train journeying across
vast deserts and mountains
to California.
Walsh didn't want a known
star to play the lead.
He was looking for someone
who would, in his words,
'be a true replica
of the pioneer type.'
He didn't want the audience
to see a part being acted.
He wanted them to
see the real thing.
Again, in his words, 'someone to
get out there and act natural,
be himself.'
Then he happened upon
the young Duke Morrison,
lugging a table
across a soundstage."
And here's Walsh recalling that.
"'He was in his early
20s and laughing.
The expression on his face was
so warm and wholesome that I
stopped and watched.
I noticed the fine physique of
the boy, his careless strength,
the grace of his movements.
What I needed was a feeling
of honesty, of sincerity,
and he had it.'
Within a few weeks, after
a quick screen test,
Duke would be signed
up for the part
of Breck Coleman, the
fearless young scout,
in an ambitious film to
be called The Big Trail.
He would more than double his
income from $35 to $75 a week.
He had to let his hair grow
long and learn to throw a knife.
And he would have a new name--
John Wayne.
Already as the young
frontiersman in The Big Trail,
the man the world
would come to know
as John Wayne is recognizable.
He is more athletic
and beautiful
than we remember him
from his later pictures,
and he has a sweetness
and shyness of youth
that recedes over time.
But he is tough and in charge.
He has a natural air of command.
The widescreen film
is still visually
stunning and
interesting to watch,
but it was an epic flop and
left Wayne languishing in B
movie purgatory
for almost a decade
before John Ford
decided to make him
a star as The Ringo Kid in
the great Western Stagecoach.
Ford was inspired by something
similar to Raoul Walsh's
inspiration when he chose Duke
Morrison for The Big Trail.
And these are Ford's words.
'It isn't enough for an
actor to look the part
and say his lines well.
Something else
has to come across
to audiences, something
which no director can
instill or create--
the quality of
being a real man.'
Ford added that Wayne 'was
the only person I could think
of at the time who could
personify great strength
and determination
without talking much.'
That sounds easy,' says Ford.
But it's not.
Either you have
it or you don't.'
John Wayne had it.
As James Baldwin
wrote, 'One does not
go to see Katharine Hepburn, or
Bette Davis, Humphrey Bogart,
or John Wayne act.
One goes to watch them be.'
And Duke Morrison
decided that John Wayne
would be the kind of
man he and the audience
wanted to believe in.
Whatever his flaws-- and
Wayne's characters had many--
he would present on
screen a character that
had something admirable in it.
This character certainly added
dimensions with his great films
like Red River, The Searchers.
But his essence was discernible
from the earliest days.
He had courage
and self-reliance,
obstinacy, and even
ruthlessness, but also
generosity of soul and spirit.
As his biographer
Scott Eyman put it,
'He had the kind of spirit
that makes fireman rush
into a burning building because
it's the right thing to do.'
He had humor,
gusto, irascibility.
He was bold, defiant, ambitious,
heedless of consequences,
occasionally mistaken, primarily
alone, larger than life.
As one of Wayne's
colleagues said,
'John Wayne was what every
young boy wants to be like,
and what every old man
wishes he had been."
Wayne was 32 when he made
Stagecoach and 69 when he made
his last film, The Shootist.
In that film, he plays the dying
gunfighter, John Bernard Books.
His oft-quoted
line from that film
would have been right at
home in The Big Trail.
'I won't be wronged.
I won't be insulted.
I won't be laid a hand on.
I don't do these
things to other people,
and I require the
same from them.'
For 25 years--
from 1949 to 1974--
Wayne was among the
top 10 box office stars
every year but one.
And he was more than
a star for his time.
Well into the 21st century,
35 years after his death,
he was still listed as one of
America's five favorite movie
stars.
He became 'indivisibly
associated with America
itself,' in Eyman's words.
On his 72nd birthday,
May 26, 1979,
as Wayne lay dying of cancer at
UCLA Medical Center, the United
States Congress, in a
unanimous bipartisan vote,
approved an order signed
by President Jimmy Carter
for striking a congressional
gold medal in his honor.
Wayne would be the 85th
recipient of the medal.
The first recipient
was George Washington.
Winston Churchill was awarded
the medal just a few years
before John Wayne.
As President Carter said,
'Wayne's ruggedness,
the tough independence, the
sense of personal conviction
and courage on and off the
screen reflected the best
of our national character.'
Wayne's friend,
actress Maureen O'Hara,
testifying before
Congress, said,
'To the people of
the world, John Wayne
is not just an actor
and a very fine actor.
John Wayne is the United
States of America.
He is what they
believe it to be.
He is what they hope it will be.
And he is what they hope
it will always be.'"
So that's a John Wayne story.
And here's one about
an American whose name
won't be as familiar
to you, probably.
But you will want
to know it, I hope.
It's called, We're
All Americans.
"Eli Parker was born in 1828
to Elizabeth and William
Parker of the Tonawanda
Seneca tribe of the Iroquois
Confederacy in Western New York.
Parker became a leader in his
tribe at a very young age,
trained as a civil
engineer, and earned himself
a reputation in that field.
In 1857, when he
was 29 years old,
he moved to Galena, Illinois
as a civil engineer,
working for the
Treasury Department.
And there his life
took a fateful turn.
He became friends with a
fellow named Ulysses S. Grant.
In these years, Grant
was an ex-army officer,
working as a clerk in
his father's store.
Parker later liked to tell the
story of coming to Grant's aid
in a bar room fight in Galena--
the two of them back to
back, fighting their way out
against practically
all the other patrons.
At about 5 feet 8
inches and 200 pounds,
the robust Parker referred
to himself as a 'savage Jack
Falstaff.'
When the Civil War came
on, Parker several times
tried to join the Union
Army as an engineer
but was turned down because
he was not a citizen.
When he approached
Secretary of State William
Seward about a
commission, he was
told the war was an
affair between white men,
that he should go home.
We will settle our own
troubles among ourselves
without any Indian aid,
thank you very much.
Eventually, with
Grant's endorsement,
Parker received a commission
with the rank of Captain
as assistant adjutant
general for volunteers.
By late 1863, he had been
transferred to Grant's staff
as military secretary.
He soon became familiarly known
as the Indian at headquarters
and was promoted to
lieutenant colonel
and later to brigadier general.
He may have saved Grant's
life, or at least prevented
his capture, on a night
in the wilderness campaign
in 1864, when
Grant and his staff
were riding into enemy
lines in the dark,
unbeknownst to themselves.
But Parker is rightly
most remembered
for something that
happened in the parlor
of a private residence in
the village of Appomattox
Courthouse on April 9, 1865.
In the days preceding,
Union armies
had captured the
city of Petersburg
and the Confederate
capital of Richmond.
Grant and the federal
army at the Potomac
had put Confederate
General Robert E.
Lee and the Army of Northern
Virginia in such a position
that in the late
afternoon of April 7,
Grant, sitting on the veranda
of his hotel headquarters
in Farmville, said to a
couple of his generals,
I have a great mind to
summon Lee, to surrender.
He immediately wrote a
letter, respectfully inviting
Lee to surrender, and
had it sent to him
under a flag of truce.
It took Lee a couple of days
of desperate failed maneuvers
to come around to the idea.
But by the morning of April
9, Lee had concluded--
and these are his words--
that 'there is nothing left me
to do but to go and see General
Grant, and I would
rather die 1,000 deaths.'
They agreed to meet in
the village of Appomattox
Courthouse to discuss terms.
Grant had been
riding hard for days
on rough roads in rough weather.
When he met Lee in the
parlor of the brick house
where they had
arranged to meet, he
had on dirty boots, an old
suit without his sword,
and without any
distinguishing mark of rank,
except the shoulder
straps of the lieutenant
general on a woolen blouse.
Lee was decked out from head to
toe in all the military finery
he had at his disposal.
After introductions and
not much small talk,
Lee asked Grant on what
terms he would receive
the surrender of Lee's army.
Grant told him, all
officers and men
would be paroled
and disqualified
from taking up arms again
until properly exchanged.
And all arms
ammunition and supplies
were to be delivered up
as captured property.
Lee said those were
the terms he expected,
and he asked Grant
to commit them
to writing, which he did on the
spot, and showed them to Lee.
With minor revisions,
Lee accepted,
and Grant handed the document
to his senior adjutant
general, Theodore
Bowers, to put into ink.
In Grant's words,
'this was a document
that would effectively
put an end to four
years of devastating Civil War.
Bowers' hands were so unsteady
from nerves that he had
to start over three
or four times,
going through several sheets
of paper in a failed effort
to prepare a fair copy for the
signatures of the generals.'
So Grant asked Eli
Parker to do it,
which he did without trouble.
This gave occasion for Lee
and Parker to be introduced.
When Lee recognized that
Parker was an American Indian,
he said, 'I'm glad to see
one real American here.'
Parker shook his
hand and replied,
'We are all Americans.'"
The American story
is still young
and is already the
greatest story ever written
by human hands and minds.
It is a story of freedom
the likes of which
the world had never seen.
It is endlessly
interesting and instructive
and will continue
unfolding in word and deed
as long as there are Americans.
The stories I think
are most important
are those about what it is that
makes America beautiful, what
it is that makes America good,
and therefore, worthy of love.
Only in this light,
I think, can we
see clearly what it is
that might make America
better and more beautiful.
Thank you.